hola buenos días pues la de renuncia de
edad y lo que pone de manifiesto es que
los políticos libaneses están mucho más
interesados en sus propios asuntos que
en haber formado gobierno un requisito
necesario para poder recibir las sedes
internacionales el problema principal es
que no ha habido acuerdo en la cartera
de finanzas que tradicionalmente
llevaban los grupos chií hezbollah yabal
y que al ser ahora un gobierno
independiente se buscaba precisamente un
candidato independiente una propuesta
que tanto hezbollah como amal y también
el presidente michel aún han rechazado y
es lo que han hecho que han bloqueado la
formación de este gobierno ya ha llevado
después de un mes a depp a renunciar por
la falta de voluntad política de los
ministros así es el pero en medio de una
crisis tan fuerte como la que se vive en
ese momento el líbano que significa para
el país seguir sin un gobierno
bueno estamos hablando de un país
hundido económicamente que además
destrozado por la explosión del puerto
hace un mes
difícilmente podría aguantar una
inestabilidad política para poder
recibir las ayudas económicas es
necesario y es lo que exige la comunidad
internacional que se ponga a cabo las
reformas políticas y económicas y por
eso les dieron la última oportunidad de
formar un gobierno independiente ahora
que este gobierno ha fracasado
difícilmente la comunidad internacional
podrá otra vez tener confianza en los
políticos libaneses y seguramente habrán
más sanciones para el grupo hezbollah
porque la comunidad internacional lo que
está buscando desde el principio es que
hezbollah que aparte de ser partido es
una milicia armada pierda el tanto poder
que tiene en el país